you know I always love seeing the videos
of you and Kawai together because it
feels like you're one of the people that
he is just most comfortable with like
every personality moment that I see with
Kawai you're also there why do you think
you all have that connection what about
you makes Kawai feel so comfortable um
good question I don't know um you know I
guess you know I I I get them I
understand them um I Vibe with them you
know we're on the same page with one
another
um you know there's just a mutual
respect there you know um and uh again I
feel like I allow him to be himself um
with no judgment no you know
expectations um you know I just
appreciate you know uh who he is and and
what he's done in his league and so you
know I I don't know um he's so like
unintentionally
funny everything he says it's like he's
not trying to make a joke but it's
hilarious yeah but I that's that's Kawai
like that's Kawai um I think people
don't realize like he is as normal as
possible and he's a funny dude and he's
you know charismatic and he has a
personality like I don't know why people
undermine that he's just a like think
he's a robot like that's the craziest
thing to me um before you met him did
you also think he was a bit of a
robot uh No I gave him the benefit of
the doubt you know I gave him the
benefit out a doubt uh but at the same
time I didn't know much about him yeah
um and you know there's always a mystery
you've seen the memes memes was going on
way before we were teammates of him and
his personality but then being a
teammate of his oh like he's normal as
anybody else yeah I like this guy yeah
he actually talks a lot like when you
get to know him he actually talks a lot
he's he's cool you know really really
down the Earth dude um and so yeah we
just we hit it off and we just connect
that's great no I I love the friendship
that you all have